this video is brought to you by Dollar
Shave Club you can get started with
Dollar Shave Club today for just $5
which gets you a neat shaving set more
on them in a bit or if you're desperate
to support the show and well if you are
you're a hero you can just go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
biographic right now there's also a link
below and let's get into it New York
City the Big Apple it's the country's
beating heart it's wild weird and
wonderful and in order to truly
understand how it turns into the
metropolis that it is today you'll have
to take a look at one of the most
influential figures in the city's
history it's a tale of corruption fraud
bribery ostentatious wealth a little bit
of creative legal interpretation and a
lot of sheer audacity and willpower one
of the most important figures of 19th
century New York was William McGirt we'd
also known as boss tweed and the tiger
of Tammany fer reasons that will soon
become clear on one hand weed was
responsible for building some of the
infrastructure that made it possible for
the city to grow he improved the water
and sewer systems he built city streets
and oversaw the construction of major
landmarks like the Metropolitan Museum
of Art Central Park and the Brooklyn
Bridge and also the American Museum of
Natural History on the other hands he
was one of the most corrupt politicians
ever to rise to power in the United
States by the time he died in 1878 he
was estimated that his network of
cronies had stolen millions from the
state a sum that's estimated to be as
high as three point five billion dollars
in today's money so how did he do it
well that's at the very heart of today's
story
[Music]
tweed was born on April the 3rd 1823 and
according to most accounts he had an
average Charlotte he had the basic sort
of education typically available to
children growing up in Manhattan at the
time peep once completed a brief stint
as a chair makers apprentice tweeds life
seemed to take a dramatic shift when as
a teenager he attached himself to his
local volunteer fire company here's
where a bit of secondary history is
needed to truly do the story justice the
volunteer firefighting companies of the
mid 19th century were nothing like the
ones of today as a fairly new idea
volunteer companies they were sort of
half gang half returned 'ti with only a
small amount of effort actually reserved
for actual firefighting companies
inspired strong allegiances among their
members and they were closely tied to
the local politics of their area it
wasn't unusual to have more than one
company racing to put out a fire only to
get distracted by the sight of a rival
company and having the entire thing
dissolved into a massive street brawl
even as a teen tweeds had quite the
reputation as one of his company's best
brawlers to eat attached himself to
Engine Company 33 which was also known
as black joke for an idea of just what
sort of folks this particular Engine
Company attracted let's jump out a few
decades for just a moment in 1863 New
York was torn apart by a series of draft
riots that led to more than a hundred
deaths since somewhere around 1.5
million dollars in damages leading the
way were the men of the black joke angry
that firefighters weren't exempt from
the draft that was sending able-bodied
men across the country to fight in the
Civil War they started by burning down
the city's draft office and it kicked
off to a full-scale riot that's ended
into race riots that were so bad that
the company retreated from the front
lines and went to defend their own
neighborhood from the burning pillaging
and beatings that is the company tweed
joined as 18 where he first made a name
for himself after establishing himself
as a charismatic yet street-smart figure
in the neighborhood he kicked off his
political campaign and secured a
position as an alderman of the seventh
Ward an alderman is a judicial official
that oversaw some - civil and criminal
cases and worked closely with the mayor
that was in 1852 tweed arose through the
political ranks fast by 1853 here a seat
in the House of Representatives
life in Washington DC though it didn't
suit him and he headed back to the city
after just a single term he kept his
finger firmly on the pulse of the city's
political scene and in 1856 he landed a
position on the city's new Board of
Supervisors from there he didn't look
back okay so now for a little background
about one of the organizations that
shaped New York City through the 1800's
Tammany Hall was founded in the 1780s
and was originally meant to be a
fraternal society where like-minded
individuals could get together socialize
and talk about politics their actions
became increasingly political as the
decades went on by the 1840s they're
firmly established themselves as an arm
of the Democratic Party even more
importantly they developed a deep
connection with the city's ever-growing
population of immigrants particularly
the Irish Tammany Hall helped countless
new arrivals get jobs set up lives and
even achieve u.s. citizenship in turn
Tammany Hall got votes for candidates
that they put forward in elections
across the city and the state it seems
really to just work out for everyone now
Tammany Hall always had a bit of a stink
of corruption about it as early as the
1850s it was clear that those who were
capable of rising to power within the
organization were also the types a color
outside of the line Isaak Fowler was the
grand sachem in other words the boss
before tweed stepped into the position
in 1868 since his term was ended when he
was charged with embezzlement and had to
flee to Mexico now in spite of this
scandal the political machine though was
a Tammany Hall it kept increasing its
influence over the city this time with
boss tweed at the helm tweed spent most
of the decade establishing himself in
the neighborhood where he was already
known as a larger-than-life character
quite literally at a time when the
average high for a man was five foot six
tweed towered over most at an impressive
height of about six feet he topped the
scales at almost 300 pounds - at a time
when the average weight was closer to
150 AD in the ten and a half carat
diamonds that he liked to wear all the
time and you had something of an
imposing figure on your hands it was
easy for such a memorable man to be the
center of attention and that was a
significant part of why tweed was so
successful it wasn't just a politician
sitting up on high raking in the cash he
was also on the streets shaking hands
thing out cigars and whiskey and perhaps
most importantly listening to his
constituents tweed was famous for
remembering names and faces investing
himself and the stories that people had
to tell and ultimately doing them favors
true these favors is often hand another
attached in return but as tweed was
climbing a political ladder he has an
impressively modest reputation for
honesty
[Music]
many of the positions that tweed and dis
associates held were still elected
positions and that brings the story
around to another important point just
how did tweed squad manage to get
themselves elected so regularly a big
part of their success was the fact that
the ever-growing population of Irish
immigrants saw them as an organization
that truly cared about their welfare
many had fled the great famine a
catastrophic crop failure in Ireland
that led to the deaths of somewhere
around a million people when starving
families of survivors reached New York
how many Hall welcomes them with open
arms they even helped them out with
baskets of food and coal for their fires
but it wasn't all goodwill tweed was
notorious for a brazen scheme where he
would recruit a few dozen volunteers
from their local followers ply them with
alcohol and register them in multiple
polling places he did then pay law
enforcement officers to escort them from
one polling place to the next and to
make sure that they cast their votes one
person would vote dozens of times and
all of that added up to a lot of votes
for Tammany Hall tweed also paid
officers to arrest any voting inspector
that started to get suspicious the most
flagrant instance of tweed using his
clout and influence with immigrants to
get Tammany Hall allies more votes came
in 1868 that's the year that tweed
arranged to have 44,000 immigrants
become naturalized citizens in the weeks
prior to the major election it didn't go
unnoticed either when Tammany Hall
members were elected to officers of the
mayoral level and all the way up to
governor of New York the House of
Representatives put together a committee
to determine the extent of tweeds
interference with the elections and well
nothing came of it the so called tweed
ring only continued to increase their
power and influence the same yeah he was
under investigation for interfering with
elections tweed was named to the head of
Tammany Hall and elected to the New York
Senate those were just stepping stones
though while tweed was serving as House
rep at the federal level he had made
friends across party lines that allowed
him to pass a charter shifting the
responsibilities of local governance
particularly those that concerned budget
and oversight out of the hands of
federally appointed boards and into the
control of locally appointed authorities
and this was truly the brilliant part
remember we mentioned that Washington DC
had a mentor tweeds liking and he opted
to leave there
politics to return to New York City well
when he did that that very same city
charter was waiting for him and it
passed complete control of the Treasury
into his direct authority he and his
cronies now had absolute control over
what the Treasury paid out and they took
advantage of that in every way that they
could just before we continue today I do
quickly want to thank Dollar Shave Club
for sponsoring this episode if you're
looking for a great way to support this
show and get something at an incredible
price in return Dollar Shave Club is the
way to do it because you can get started
with their starter set for just $5 look
obviously I don't shave my face but I do
shave my head which i think is an even
greater challenge having shave those
things at different points in my life
the head is harder so anything this can
hands along the head it can handle on
the face now I used to use terrible
cheaper razors and I used to get pretty
cut up indeed on here this is quite
funny have a nice cut of beef not a nice
cutter face there's no such thing as a
nice cutter face but I've got a bad cut
of head no more getting cut up thanks to
Dollar Shave $5 for all this stuff you
get the executive razor thing here you
get this there's four blades in here
obviously I put one on my razor and
there's this shave butter
dr. Carver's shave butter it's fantastic
I rub this all over my head and I just
get shaving so just go to
dollarshaveclub.com /bi graphics to get
your starter set for just $5 and then
regular refills at a regular price
dollarshaveclub.com
/by graphics and let's get back to it
no building our enterprise illustrates
the extents of the Tweed rings
corruption better than the old New York
County Courthouse the building is a
stunning display of 19th century
architecture and craftsmanship and it's
also known as one of the most prominent
legacies of tweeds reign at Tammany Hall
it also ended up being one of the most
expensive buildings ever built in the
United States costing even more than the
US Capitol building for the simple
reason that tweed and his cronies were
in charge of both issuing the bills and
paying them from the city's coffers the
Tweed ring was unthinkably audacious
when it came to manipulating these
construction bills the original budget
for the entire building was $250,000 a
hefty sum at the time to give you an
idea of just how much the courthouse
ended up costing that original budget
was only enough to pay the bill for the
purchase of the courthouses brooms other
items were just as costly plumbing cept
the city back more than a million
dollars the thermometers ended up at a
rather pricey $7,500 and a set of three
tables and four chairs came to a grand
total of a hundred and seventy nine
thousand seven hundred and twenty nine
dollars and believe me there were a lot
more of these chairs the amounts of
chair money that tweed actually build
the city for they could have bought
around three hundred and fifteen
thousand chairs and just for reference
that would be chairs going on for about
17 miles Carver for the building cost
around five million dollars largely
because there was enough carpet order to
cover City Hall part three times and so
what did they do with all that carpets
well nothing because it was ordered from
companies that just didn't exist now
some companies did exist before
construction started tweeted
conveniently bought quarry it was that
quarry that was used to source all of
the marble for the courthouse and that
bill alone was higher than the entire
cost of building another courthouse in
Brooklyn not all of the money was going
right into Tweets pockets as he also
made sure that his fellow officers at
Tammany Hall were well cared for the
grand marshal at the time was Andrew J
Garvey and he earns the nickname Prince
of plasterers after he ended up
pocketing around three million dollars
for the work he did on the courthouse
and for the subsequent repairs to his
original labor so Hamish that the whole
thing end up costing when the state
legislature approved the bill for two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars that
was the equivalent of around six million
dollars in today's money why
finally finished the bill was twelve
million dollars adjusted for inflation
that's about the equivalent of two
hundred million dollars today it's no
wonder that at this point people started
catching on while there were plenty of
people willing to look the other way
when it came to boss tweets criminal
ways not everyone was so willing to
allow the Tweed ring to keep running rod
across the city one of those determines
he bring down the corruption of Tammany
Hall was Thomas Nast Nast was a German
immigrant who settled in New York City
and discovered very early in life that
he had a natural artistic talent the
timing was excellent with the start of
the Civil War Americans were growing
increasingly interested in what was
going on in other parts of the country
and specifically in the war
newspapers worked still a way that many
people got their information and Nast's
drawings of some of the most famous
battles of the war catapulted him to
fame he was one of Abraham Lincoln's
favorite propagandists since he took on
the big issues of slavery war and
eventually political corruption that was
a bigger deal than you might realize
because his illustrations reached an
entire group of people who otherwise
wouldn't have cared for what was in the
paper and those people were the
illiterate nastas working at Harper's
Weekly when tweed was running Tammany
Hall his campaign so shine a spotlight
directly on the rampant political
corruption that dominated the
institution started by calling them on
voter fraud and had only escalated from
there early on Nast long with reporters
that new york times struggled to get
something to stick to the Tweed ring
despite the fact that everyone knew what
was going on uncovering concrete
evidence it proved really difficult
until 1871 that is while tweed had gone
above and beyond to keep his
constituents on his good side Nast was
not so easily swayed it's also important
to note the Nast's campaign wasn't out
of any righteous indignation or
determination to clean up the city no
matter what the cost
Nast was just a rabid devotee of the
Republican Party and as such he
staunchly opposed the idea that the
Irish working-class immigrants were
anything but trouble since tweed was so
closely allied with that portion of New
York City's population he clearly had to
go and on July the 18th 1871 Nast and
his colleagues at the Times were given a
gift
one of tweeds associates was a man named
Jimmy O'Brien and O'Brien
believed that he wasn't being treated
fairly in the grand scheme of things so
he did something that had to have taken
an insane amount of courage he took
duplicates of the city's Ledger's he
strolled into the Times and he handed
them to an editor named Lewis Jennings
then he just walked away the ties began
running all the sordid details of tweeds
operation and that's when Nast really
swung into high gear until this moment
of reckoning when they were handed
actual proof and concrete numbers his
cartoons they were mere personal attacks
he couldn't prove anything aside from
the fact that tweed was wealthy but
making fun of that it didn't really have
any effect
but when Nast started drawing cartoons
showing tweed as a fallen Emperor is
passing the blame onto others and as
seeing himself as too powerful to be
contained by a prison it was
illustrating a more abstract situation
in a way that everyone could understand
and it was boss tweed himself who best
summed up the problem he now had by
saying I don't care a straw for your
newspaper articles my constituents don't
know how to read but as they can't help
seeing them damned pictures well it was
all downhill from there things started
happening fast after a Bryant handed
over proof of what tweed and his cronies
had done to the city members of the
Tweed ring started to flee the country
ahead of the fallout that they knew was
now inevitable and tweed himself was
arrested in October surprisingly he was
released on bail and he was allowed to
run in a local election and even more
surprisingly he won but the end it was
nigh and as the following few years they
would be marred by a series of trials
that were appropriately held in these
still unfinished Tweed courthouse
it wasn't until 1873 that tweed was
found guilty on 204 of the 220 charges
that were brought against him he was
sentenced to serve a 12 year jail term
that was quickly reduced it was also
ordered to pay a fine of twelve thousand
seven hundred and fifty dollars at the
same time tweed lost his freedom Tammany
Hall lost their boss but it wasn't the
end for them they passed their
leadership into the hands of a man named
John Kelly he made major strides in
overhauling Tammany Hall and its image
into something more in line with what
anti-corruption campaigners and
reformers had in mind didn't last long
though voter fraud came back with the
very next leader
over in 1888 by the beginning of the
20th century there was another group
that had a vested interest in Tammany
Hall and that was the mob when it came
time for the 1932 presidential elections
the Tammany Hall delegates were escorted
to the Democratic National Convention by
the likes of Mayr Lansky Lucky Luciano
and Frank Costello afterwards FDR
delivered some major blows to the
all-encompassing power of Tammany Hall
impasse by restricting immigration and
limiting their core supporters things
they were never quite the same bands
after a brief scramble fair in the 1950s
Tammany Hall disappeared in the mid
1960s its doors they simply closed and
its properties were sent to auction but
now let's get back to tween because his
story it's not quite over yet it turns
out that even as jail time wasn't much
of a punishment tweed served his time in
a private room in Blackwell's islands
with a window looking out over his
domain
when his year was RP was brought up
again on civil charges prosecutors were
hoping to recover some of the money that
he had funneled out of the city's
coffers and when he wasn't able to make
bail this time he was confined to the
Ludlow Street Jail
there is of course gonna be a but here
tweed cell was a two-bedroom set of
rooms with a small library and his own
personal age it talked to the warden
into letting him have regular visitors
and he was even allowed to head out into
Central Park for the occasional carriage
ride on December the 4th 1875 he headed
to his home with an escort of two guards
after telling them he was going to check
on his sick wife he strolled out the
front door crossed the Hudson River into
a carriage and escaped to New Jersey
where he went on the run under the alias
John Secor in the meantime the courts
had continued without him and ruled that
yes he did owe the city six million
dollars with nothing really left to lose
tweed continued life on the lam hopping
on a schooner and sailing down the
Atlantic coast he met up with a man who
was going by the name of William hunt
it's not entirely clear who hunt was but
we do know that the deer hopped a
fishing boat to Cuba they were
immediately stopped for not having the
proper paperwork but before the
governments could coordinate to arrest
in the jumped on yet another boat that
was bound for Spain unfortunately for
tweeds the six week crossing gave
authorities more than enough time to
send word to Spain that they had a
fugitive headed for their Shores Spanish
officials they were waiting on the dock
when he got that there's one last little
footnote to the story today that adds to
the sheer outrageousness of the tale
authorities they weren't sure who they
were looking for but they were able to
identify tweed based on one of Nast's
cartoons it was appropriately one that
depicted him in the stripes outfit of a
convict
hunt was released but tweed was shipped
back to the US only 11 months after
escaping he was back in his old cell on
Ludlow Street he was a hundred pounds
lighter with hair that had gone
completely white at this point it was a
broken man Swede finally agreed to
confess to everything that had done in
exchange for his freedom and in 1877 he
went before a special commission not
only admitted just how much money had
stolen this he also names names the list
was long and included anyone who'd ever
taken bribes to look the other way or
those who had helped with election fraud
or even those who had taken kickbacks on
his construction projects in the end the
Governor and Attorney General thanked
tweed for his cooperation withdrew their
promise to set him free and send him
back to Ludlow two weeks later on April
the 27th 1878 he died he was buried in
Greenwood Cemetery
having left New York City a completely
different place from the city it was
born in so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe
smash that notification bell so you find
out when we put out a new video and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]